so alexi in his big league debut 23
years old youngest pitcher the rangers
have used this year 3-2
and he got blackman there's his first
major league strikeout and it completes
a perfect first you can smile a little
bit that's pretty exciting on the
change-up take a look at the location
first the mechanics of aj alexi but then
the pitch the swing and the myth and
he's got his first bigly hitter in his
book john marquez's 27th start of the
season his 12th out on the road for the
rainbows
upstairs ball four so and that's part of
the reason why right there fifth walk
for yani hernandez in his very short
time here in the big leagues but he is
on setting the table here in the first
while outside diaz throwing down and the
tag good
so another elias diaz god stealing
that's his 14th of the season now
tor diaz is like
white running on it
3-2 pitch and these strikes out swinging
so alexi with his second strikeout
he's gotten blackman and trevor story 33
rbis this month in fact the highest
single month total
in baseball this year and he's going to
add to it with a drive down the left
field line it'll bounce off the wall
rather than get over it but cj will
cruise into second with a double
boy another example of a ball coming off
the bat you thought was going to carry
out of here and it died although cj gets
the one out double
so here's rhino tapia back with the
rockies you see his numbers for the year
at the bottom of your screen
it's not a pretty decent season and it
goes right after the first pitch pops
this one up back of second base
and it's handled by counter falafel the
inning is done so the rockies get a man
to second but leave him there alexi with
two scoreless to start his career
it's this one on the ground up the
middle diving stop behind second but no
play to be out there for trevor story
that's a hit for low scoreless game with
a runner at second and two outs and
martin will
sky up all the center field
sam hilliard grabs it and the hit by low
does no damage we go to the third
scoreless
his numbers really remarkably consistent
between the work he did
at double a and triple a a bunt third
base sign bare hand play and throw on
the run nicely done by kinder philippa
he gets hillyard two away
there you go that's the uh first punch
out tonight for eneman on the slider
o2 pitch
and this one lined out to the gap right
center field that's a base hit loyote
with good speed turns he's going for two
the throw is late eliot has a double
here in the third inning his first extra
base hit of the season
it's good to see him get this break you
mentioned some of the hard contact and
just not yielding hits for him this is a
breaking ball sat in the middle of zone
you can see that short swing here from
leote nice line drive almost fooled a
little bit but he's still able to square
it up but with that speed and no doubter
that this was going to be a double it's
fun to watch him run
as he just glides into second base and
turn that into a stand-up double not too
many guys in the league are standing up
at second base all right rangers need a
hit to get that first run in
kinder philippa might be just the guy to
do that
count for marquez
that ball out to left field and right in
rymel tapia's glove so the rockies get
out of it once again leaving a runner at
third fourth plate appearance tonight
for these rockies of at least seven
pitches they've had some lengthy ones a
3-2
and he got him swinging and pozo had to
pick it up and then put the tag on story
but he does two away
and
trevor
play
the hometown kid showing off in the
field well he tried to make the diving
stop earlier he said well i couldn't
make the throw on that one because i
wasn't going to get the guy so i'm just
going to make the old routine reach spin
and then on the throw money i mean this
was this was a great play all the way
around there's dj peters start of the
year with the dodgers
this ball hit hard out to left field
that's carrying well it is good
and he crushed the guy's beer in the
process
now dj peters home run number eight and
he has the rangers in front one nothing
but black
managing the rockies for the fifth year
and there's a pick off of tapia at first
well he tried him a handful of times and
that time just finally got him
it's close
3-2
got him swinging
and that completes five shutout innings
for aj alexey in his big league debut
and his family loves it it's one nothing
rangers two out nobody on here in the
home fifth rangers leading one nothing
and here's a ball driven by leote deep
into center field hillard going back
he's at the wall he leaps and it's gone
a line drive smash just a little to the
left of dead center leote tavares hits
his first home run of the 2021 campaign
to give texas a two-nothing lead
josh boris taking over now 50 games on
the season 4.30 era for this rangers
right-hander
ground ball
to the right of second base
johnny hernandez way over there makes
the play and it completes a very quick
10 pitch inning
this one lined out to left field tapia
on the run and it's over his head and
that's a base hit
scrambling for second base nathaniel law
when he's in there
his second hit of the ball game
and he continues to swing it well
and has seven home runs in those 25
games and he shoots this one out to
center field that one drops in base hit
low around third beasley waves him here
comes the throw
and they
got him
oh man
will little
i think he probably like
me
wasn't real sure
so that brings up nick solank
solac going the opposite way that one's
deep it's gone
opposite field shot
for nick solad
it's four-nothing rangers just want that
big hit for trevor right after a two-hit
game yesterday and then being in his
hometown
trevor goes deep flip the bat right away
let it fly to the second deck for trevor
story the irving texas native gets a
hometown greeting from his friends and
family points up to him as he's rounding
third out of baby trevor
there's the one two
and a grounder to the right side it's
going to hit the outfield and rymel's
speed he's safe so a two-out single for
rymel with elias diaz
1-1 and that'll be
a base hit for diaz tapia is going to go
first to third and diaz will stretch it
to extra bases
so a double for diaz and now
a real scoring threat with sam hilliard
coming up
garrett hampson will pinch in for
hilliard 2-2
swing it a bit strike three so martin
fights back and he gets hampson and the
inning is over rangers get out of a
little jam
2-2 to joe
and there we go finally a hit for the
top of the order they row for eight with
a walk before that and connor joe with a
lead off single well with two outs
that'll bring up the rocky's offense for
the day trevor story with the solo home
run and his last at-bat in the seventh
here's the 2-2 from patton
and trevor
out to right center field and over the
wall
home run city for trevor story his wife
mali likes it and the family can stand
up once again sending the i love you
signals and so are rockies fans right
back to story because he put them in the
game made it a one-run game
the first time in six years a ranger
starter making his debut
would win and this one up the middle
caught out there by solac positioned
perfectly this one is over and the
rangers take the opener 4-3
and it's a win for aj alexey
in his major league debut